يذهب الناس في السودان إلى
عطلة العيد المهمة التي تصادف
نهاية شهر رمضان مع ثلاث
محاولات فاشلة على الأقل لوقف إطلاق النار في كل مرة
تحاول فيها الجهود الدبلوماسية الإقليمية والدولية إقناع هذين
الجنرالين المتحاربين بالموافقة على قتال إيجابي،
وسرعان ما انهار كل منهما.
ألقى باللوم على الجانب الآخر لانتهاكه
أولاً، ولهذا السبب يقول الناس في السودان لشبكة
CNN إنهم غير متفائلين، ولكن حتى مع
وقف إطلاق النار لمدة ثلاثة أيام، توصي الأمم المتحدة
باحترامه
الآن، ولا يرون أنه سيكون هناك وقف لإطلاق النار
في بلادهم.  الاهتمام لأن
كلاهما يعملان أو يبدو أنهما يعملان
على افتراض أن وقف إطلاق النار
من شأنه أن يحد من المدى الذي
يمكن أن يحققا فيه
نصرًا فوريًا أو على الأقل تحقيق
مكاسب عسكرية مع مقتل أكثر من 300 شخص
بالفعل وأكثر من 3000
جريح.  من المرجح أن
تزيد الأعداد كلما طال أمد هذا الصراع،
حيث أن هناك قلقًا دوليًا كبيرًا
بشأن البلدان التي لديها
موظفين في سفاراتها في البلد الذي
لديه مواطنيه، ولم
يتمكنوا من إجلاء الولايات المتحدة الآن تضيف
قدرة إضافية في
جيبوتي المجاورة  في حالة كانت هناك حاجة
لإجلاء موظفي السفارة أو لتأمين
السفارة، فإن الولايات المتحدة لديها
قاعدة عسكرية دائمة في معسكر ليمونير في
جيبوتي، وهذا سيشمل
مشاة البحرية من هناك بالإضافة إلى
طائرات إضافية، إنها مجرد حالة طوارئ في هذا
الوقت، وزارة الدفاع هي
قال لشبكة CNN، لكن كلما طال أمد هذا الصراع
على كل شيء، كان لا بد من التخطيط
لـ
Larry madowa CNN في نيروبي